good morning -- the rules
committee for Thursday March
twenty first is hereby called
please be advised of audio
today's per season has also been
televised -- man factored
please call the roll Cooley
Cunningham Carillo here
Lara Grayson Kamlager-Dove
here Maienschein Mathis
quirk Silva here from
Wicks we have a we
have a consent agenda this
morning -- is our most on
the consent agenda second
move on this Crescenta by
Mister Mathis thank you very
much a man short term fiscal
Cooley hi Cooley aye Cunningham
Carillo Kamala art for
Mason I can motor drive
Kamlager-Dove I mean trying
trying trying on Mathis Mathis
aye aye quirk Silva hi virtual
by Romans Ramos I rivers
three of us I works fine works
aye of the motion is passed
and the rules committee
is internet thank you for